hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey it's Monday and we're
gonna go underwater with 20th Century
Fox's and Disney's underwater
yep let's go into it now shout it away
[Music]
[Music]
Colleen wings vincent cassell persister
hardcore alien vibes yeah
Wow
undies
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
he's definitely
Lovecraftian mythos underwater what they
got going on I paired this literally
legged you didn't tell me this was
underwater I would just think this was a
space movie that happened to feature
lots of wood because this looks like
yeah sci-fi horror thriller just with
water instead of Space Center water no
and you can hear you scream much of
anything scream making fun of the alien
tagline oh hey pay attention Johnny I
have a memory that serves you that was
cool it definitely feels very Ridley
Scott inspired oh yeah I'd like the
concept of creating some type of ship
where they can they say the drill to the
bottom of the lawn the ocean they're
drilling deep down in the ocean floor
the thing with the ocean and the sea is
that there's a sea creatures that we
have not discovered yet like that's just
a weird proven fact is that there's so
many more creatures out there in the
abyss that's another thing that's kind
of reminds me of is James Cameron - yeah
it's like aliens in the abyss combined
movie especially the how like paranoid
and any it's just the way they're
shooting a lot of this I mean that that
obviously is gonna be one of the Gravier
elements but I really thought it was
needs like you have all these shots like
inside of helmets and it's like it
really feels like you're gonna be very
intimate especially with Kristen Stewart
cuz like that stuff looked super intense
like when the ship is first like man
taking on water or whatever well this is
directed by a guy who primarily has
menaced intimate ographers so it makes
sense why this film is shot so well I
wonder if he DP'd this movie himself
yeah maybe he's just doing it right he
has not and he has not also this January
release date really inspiring I don't
know if I it's something to actually be
concerned about or not I think this is
one of those films that was made quite a
while ago and then maybe shifting around
release dates since the Fox merger yeah
and this might have just been the slot
to take cuz usually a January release
date gets me a little worried don't we
have Charlie's Angels in February yeah
sure it's gonna have Chris crostata
sunsin no yeah it's been watered Suns a
good day that that's a good call
actually because they probably were like
well they think I'm Charlie's Angels
let's just dump this in January right
before then and probably ride the
Kristen Stewart hype like I could
actually see that big yeah strategy
this looks really cool the weird concern
to me is that it seems to primarily take
inspiration from then not so inspired
release Scott alien pills
I keep really reminded me of covenant
covenant it's like well you know as much
as I think it's cool to draw from alien
and usually people when they draw
familiar and they're drawing from the
first Alien movie looking at this which
this looks like those two recent 20th
Century Fox alien films that people
weren't too fond of yeah and that's kind
of like the weird concern for me I think
it's cool that Jessica hen wick is in
this movie I loved her as Colleen winged
on iron fist I don't know how much more
she's gonna contribute to this film this
feels like the Christian Stewart vincent
cassell movie primarily she's gonna
contribute just as much as Ruby Rose in
the Magnum Kristen Stewart looks great
shanterrica man yeah there pulls that
off yeah well Julie really natural she
can really change a prayer even in
Charlie's Angels she could really change
up her hairstyles she pulls it off super
well weirdly enough I mean everybody's
has the nasty Twilight Association but I
feel like there is something about her
word yeah she's able to change her look
up and change her vibe up so like every
time I see her in a trailer I always
feel like she's giving us something
really different once we really finally
let go of - it's like we're seeing with
Robert Pattinson - and I feel like
they're both in their own ways finally
getting to shed that Twilight yeah
especially with the amount of work she
seems to be getting now yeah with this
trailer I like the oppressive contained
unsettling and like an Irving tension
that's throughout it and then yeah the
style is cool and yes the concept of you
know going this far under water I feel
like is really neat the thing that will
be lackluster to me is they're obviously
not gonna really explore it it's gonna
be this sort of immediate tension based
sci-fi thriller I feel like this could
probably lean a little bit into sunshine
territory that doesn't look like it's
just gonna be like this right when you
get to Act two or something it seems
like this is probably going to occur way
later in the movie and and I like sort
of the
hidden shadows of the monsters and
you're not getting all these clear
images of it which does hearken a little
bit back to the first Ridley Scott movie
and there are things about it with you
know sea creatures that do make me
flashy Lovecraftian all the mythos
there's probably gonna be things that
have weird will be some cool explanation
and some cool no thought oh gee or some
like science fiction but uh but grounded
in some type of reality based science
that they could explore here I just
don't think they're gonna do it that
it's gonna come down to like one or two
of these guys surviving TJ Miller's
obviously dead he's like the Danny
McBride of this one but he's you know
just gonna die early on
he's probably one of the first people to
get killed I feel like although I'm mrs.
Littlefield paradox
this does remind me of a few things and
I feel like at its best maybe this could
be another life you know which is
another movie they got heavily heavy
alien comparisons and then came out and
I heard was pretty solid and pretty
thrilling I mean the thing that I wonder
about this is if there's ultimately
gonna be anything more than the style
and the intensity if it will be
well-rounded despite that you know cuz
if it's just the yelling just a really
nifty immediate sci fi thriller with
this one twist that it's all under
terrestrial water you know that could be
the perfect pick-me-up for January yeah
hopefully there's got a bit of a mood
piece to it too hopefully does its kind
of own thing
well guys are you excited to go
underwater are you meant below are you
sad that this film destroyed beyond the
Disney Fox merger it is the one that
destroyed it all no more original films
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell you could
check us out on patreon where we got
weekly Q&A Stevie show reactions stream
along some live reaction highlights
included and he does music video
reactions weekly today got to give a
shout out to someone very special that
man is Jake Stewart we were probably
gonna wait till tomorrow cuz I heard
there was a different trailer to coming
out but since the recover in this one I
wanted to say to you Jake
today's his actual birthday you've been
a longtime patron ejective ARS you've
been very sweet very kind the guys had a
girlfriend for the past few months she
is sexually satisfied but lately he's
been reading some true crime novels he's
really getting into the zodiac books the
ones that inspired the actual movies I
just want to say that you know if you're
planning on you know murdering your
girlfriend just be smart about it yeah
you know you really want to cover your
tracks and you don't want to call too
much attention to yourself that's an
easy way to get caught as a birthday
present to you if you if you need help
getting rid of her body I'm your guy oh
yeah all right dude just as a president
but don't tell anyone I like to be home
I would like to get Lucy public praise
for such things so just let me know
Ellis
well happy 22nd birthday it's a pivotal
age of sorts it's an age